Good.
Let's,
let's do,
I want to begin today with,
um,
uh,
fit,
concluding Aristotle part three.
Before I do,
however,
could I just ask the,
uh,
the people?
Yes.
Thank you so much.
And,
and your neighbor,
Joe,
would you mind?
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Uh,
uh,
just out of respect to Mr Aristotle,
it's mister deal.
I want to talk today about Aristotle Aristotles discovery of America.
So probably come as a surprise to some of you that Aristotle discovered America,
but I will get to that in a minute.
In many ways,
for Aristotle as it is for every student of politics,
the most serious,
the most difficult issue,
uh,
one confront is the problem of faction,
how to control four factions,
how to control for a conflict between factions.
And that,
uh,
is the,
issue,
uh,
addressed,
especially in books.
Four in five of the politics were Aristotle goes on to describe,
uh,
by the term polity,
the regime that he believes most successfully controls,
uh,
for the theme of faction.
The essential feature of this regime,
the policy,
which in fact he gives,
uh,
he gives the name polity or the generic,
you might say Greek word for regime.
Uh,
the,
uh,
polity is the regime that represents for Aristotle a mixture of the principles
of oligarchy and democracy.
Uh,
and therefore he says avoids dominance by either extreme,
by combining elements as it were of the fuel.
And the many,
uh,
polity is characterized by the dominance of the middle class,
the middle group,
and the middle class he says is able to achieve the confidence of both extreme
parties,
uh,
where at least it is sufficiently numerous,
to avoid the problems of class struggle.
And factional conflict with a middling element is great.
Aristotle writes factional conflicts and splits over the nature of regimes occur
least of all.
Uh,
so Aristotle in a way has discovered a long before James Madison's famous
article in federalist number 10,
the remedy for the control and containment,
so to speak,
of faction.
You remember,
many of you,
if not all of you who have read,
uh,
the first fat,
the 10th federalist paper that Madison outlines his scheme for an extended
republic,
he says,
were numerous factions in many ways,
check and balance one another,
compete with one another,
and therefore,
uh,
avoid the dominance of a single faction leading to the kind of tyranny of the
majority,
the tyranny of a majority class and Aristotle's proposal for a mixture of
oligarchy in democracy.
Sames in many ways to anticipate,
uh,
2000 years before the fact,
Madison's call for a government where powers must be separated.
And where he says in federalist 51,
uh,
ambition must be made to counteract ambition in order to avoid,
in other words,
the extremes of both tyranny and civil war.
So the inevitable conclusion that I reach and I believe any sensible a reader of
Aristotle would reach,
is that Aristotle in fact discovered the American constitution.
And we have 1500 or 2000 years before it was written.
This may seem surprising to you since of course,
Aristotle lived long before,
but that may simply be our own prejudice to think that,
uh,
my friend at the Cuny Graduate Center,
Peter Simpson,
has argued in a paper that I found quite convincing that Aristotle had in fact
discovered the American constitution.
And in fact,
I say it,
it may simply be our prejudice that he didn't.
Aristotle writes,
um,
in book two of the politics that the world is eternal in everything in it has
been discovered,
uh,
in other the earth experiences.
He says certain periodic destructions and cataclysms civilizations are reduced
to barbarism only to recover and grow again.
Uh,
if this theory you might say,
of sort of cataclysmic change is true,
we cannot rule out the possibility that a constitution like hours or even
identical to ours existed at some point in the ancient past,
uh,
in the far distant past that Aristotle knew about.
You think that's possible?
Well,
why not?
But Aristotle's mixed constitution differs from ours still in certain important
respect.
Aristotle understands the mixed constitution as a balance of classes.
The one,
the few and the many.
He doesn't sell much.
Insist as you will see in your reading on the actual separation of functions of
government putting them into separate hands.
It is enough for him.
He says if each class shares in some aspect of the governing power,
but that leads to a further difference.
Uh,
we tend to think of the separation of powers doctrine as necessary for the
security and liberty of the individual.
Don't,
don't we,
we usually think of individual freedom and security as the purpose of the
separation of power.
It is when political functions become concentrated into the hands of again,
too few hands,
uh,
that we risk arbitrary government and the endangerment to the liberty of the
individual.
But for Aristotle,
it is not the liberty of the individual.
So much is the functioning or functional wellbeing of the city that has the
highest priority.
Individual freedom may be at best,
a desirable biproduct of the Aristotelian mixed regime,
but individual freedom is not.
It's defining or principal goal.
And for anyone interested in this difference,
I suggest you contrast or compare Aristotle's account of mixed government,
uh,
to book 11 of Montesquieu Skews,
spirit of the laws,
or to some of the central federalists papers to see the way in which Mr
Aristotle revised.
Uh,
in some ways the wisdom of Madison.
And you could compare them in some way that I think would be valuable,
but not only did Madison or excuse me,
not only did Aristotle understand the importance of the separation of powers
doctrine and the kind of balance of,
uh,
of,
factions of as it's a way of controlling conflict and struggle,
but he also understood the importance of property and private property in
commerce for a flourishing republic.
We didn't really pause,
just talk much about this,
but in book two,
you remember,
he criticizes at considerable length,
Plato's republic for the excessive unity,
uh,
demands of its citizens.
And Socrates is,
uh,
demands for common ownership of property,
at least among,
uh,
the auxiliary class.
But Aristotle claimed that the city is not naturally one.
That is to say a certain diversity,
uh,
is necessary to make up a,
a city where all property is held in common.
It is more likely to suffer from common neglect,
uh,
than it is,
from,
uh,
common,
ownership.
And he clearly understands in many ways the virtues of private property and of
commerce.
It is evident,
he says,
Aristotle writes that as it becomes increasingly one,
as it becomes increasingly unified,
it the city,
it will no longer be a city,
but the city is in its nature a multitude.
And as it becomes more of a unity,
it will be like a household instead of a polis and a human being instead of a
household.
So there we see in book two Aristotle offering his criticism of the claims for
the sort of excessive,
uh,
a unification of a centralization concentration of property.
Uh,
and yet despite his,
uh,
awareness of the importance of commerce and the importance of property,
the aim of the city,
he tells us is not wealth,
is not the production of wealth.
In that way,
it would be useful to make a contrast between Aristotle and someone like Adam
Smith.
Uh,
the great law author of the wealth of nations.
if wealth were the purpose of politics,
Aristotle writes the Phoenicians,
uh,
you might say in the ancient world,
the Phoenicians where the commercial people,
uh,
par exsalonce the Phoenicians would be the best regime,
but he denies that Aristotle could,
could never endorse the view,
uh,
stated by a,
by a famous American president that the business of America is business.
Uh,
the political partnership he says,
must be regarded for the sake of noble act performed well.
Wealth property he tells us exists for the sake of virtue,
not virtue for the sake of wealth.
Okay.
And just as Aristotle would have been critical of the American tendency to
regard guard government,
uh,
as for the sake of business or for the sake of the economy.
He also criticized beforehand the American tendency to organize into clubs,
uh,
what we call political parties,
which exacerbate rather than control political conflict,
these political clubs or parties use their influence to incense,
the populace using their power to whip up dangerous passions that tend to make
American politicians closer to demagogues than to statesman.
He would also regard the peculiar American practice of elections,
uh,
read it and the Greek practice of appointing political offices by lot you would
regard elections is merely exacerbating the tendency to demagoguery where each
person seeking office plays shamelessly to the mob,
promising all manner of things that they know they will not and cannot deliver.
Yeah,
I think of almost anybody you like.
And furthermore,
by the regime,
the American regime in many ways is in principle open to all and prides itself
on a belief in equality.
No doubt.
Aristotle would re remark that it's offices are in fact open only to the rich
and to leaders who can acquire the support of the rich,
making it rather an oligarchy in the guise of a republic.
So Aristotle was not without his own critique of the American constitution.
Uh,
and,
and American political culture.
There is obviously much,
uh,
in the American regime that Aristotle would have found admirable,
even though it does not conform to his idea of the best regime,
which is the subject of the last two books of the politics book seven and eight.
Aristotle is very sketchy here,
uh,
about the structure,
the institutional structure,
the makeup of the best regime,
acknowledging it is the one,
the best regime is one where the best men rule that is to say it an it is a kind
of aristocracy,
a or an aristocratic republic.
And I want to talk about this regime,
uh,
a little bit now.
What Aristotle understands to be the requirements or the fulfillments,
the necessities,
a of this aristocratic republic.
In these parts of the politics,
Aristotle offers a serious challenge to existing Greek traditions and patterns
of political education.
Every bit in many ways is far reaching is Plato's republic.
In the first place,
he tells us the purpose of the best regime.
The purpose of Aristotle's republic is directed not to war,
but in fact to piece the citizen of the best regime.
He says,
must be able to sustain war if duty requires,
but only for the sake of peace and leisure.
Again,
a critique not only of Sparta,
but also of Athens,
and it's imperialistic ambitions.
And second,
Aristotle understands the purpose of leisure.
When he says the PR,
the end of the regime is paced and the purpose of pieces,
leisure he doesn't understand by leisure,
simply relaxation.
Uh,
enjoy enjoying your private moments,
enjoying your vacation time.
Rest does not.
Leisure does not simply mean rest or inactivity,
but leisure is necessary for education or what he sometimes calls by the term
philosophy.
And by philosophy,
he seems to suggest not so much the capacity for abstract or speculative,
but rather a kind of liberal education that he regards to be the preserve of
what he calls by the term the Mongarlowe coasts.
Literally the great soul person with a great soul man.
Mega Margallo being,
you know,
our term for great and sue costs related.
I would psyche,
salt,
soul,
psyche,
the great soul person,
the great sold man.
The gentleman is in many ways before Aristotle,
the ideal recipient of this form of education,
of liberal education.
And also in some respects the ideal or perfect audience or readership of the
book itself.
And we can see here,
we can begin to see it is clear how Aristotle's best regime differs from Plato's
intransigent demand for the rule of philosopher,
kings
mcgallows to coast,
the gentlemen,
whatever else he is is not,
it's not a philosopher in the strict sense.
Uh,
sociologically Aristotle makes clear that a [inaudible] unlike the philosopher,
is a person of some inherited wealth,
uh,
chiefly landed property,
but whose way of life will be urban.
He will be a member of what we might call the Urban Patricia.
And in the Nikah McCain ethics,
Aristotle provides us with a vivid list of the psychological and even physical
characteristics that such a person must possess.
This Magalia BSEE coasts,
such a person,
he says exhibits I sort of lofty detachment to the more or less petty things
that we most of us down.
Okay?
Aristotle tells us he is slow to act unless something of great importance is at
stake.
Okay?
He repays favor with interest so as not to be under any obligations to others.
The gentleman,
he says speaks his mind without fear or favor somewhat like the New York Times,
because to dissemble would be beneath him.
He may occasionally hurt others,
but this is not done out of deliberate cruelty.
And in addition,
Aristotle tells us such a person will possess beautiful but useless things
suggesting the possession not only of wealth,
but of a kind of cultivated aesthetic sense
as if that weren't enough.
Aristotle us that the [inaudible] gallops Yukos walk slowly because to hurry is
undignified,
is tall,
and speaks with a deep voice,
very clear about who,
uh,
again,
the ideal statesmen or reader,
uh,
potential statesman of a reader of this book would be.
But most importantly,
you might say,
what distinguishes the gentleman as a class from the philosophers is a certain
kind of knowledge or practical intelligence.
The gentleman may lack the speculative intelligence of a Socrates,
but he will possess that quality of practical rationality,
of practical judgment necessary for the administration of affairs.
Aristotle calls this kind of knowledge,
this kind of practical judgment.
He calls it by the term for nieces that I have on the blackboard and the person
who possesses it is the front of most,
a person of practical judgment.
Uh,
again,
a term that captures something of our meaning of common sense,
practical wisdom,
the capacity for judging
the capacity for judgment,
which is not the same thing,
obviously is speculative or philosophic intelligence.
The thrown of most is the person who is able to grasp the fitting or the
appropriate,
the appropriate thing to do out of the complex arrangements that make up any
situation and above all such a person embodies that special quality of insight
and discrimination that distinguishes him or her from people.
Again of more theoretical or speculative cast of mind.
How is this quality of for nieces of judgment,
of practical wisdom of horse sense?
How was it acquired?
Aristotle tells us that this kind of knowledge is appropriate,
is a kind of knowledge most appropriate to politics.
Again,
it is neither and he's clear about,
he wants to be clear about this.
It is neither the theoretic knowledge and simply an abstract truth,
nor is it the productive knowledge.
What he calls tech the productive knowledge used in the manufacture of use for
artifacts.
What is it then?
It is a knowledge of how to act with the purpose of action is acting well.
You might say it is less a body of true propositions.
Then a shrewd sense of knowhow or political savvy.
It's kind of knowledge entails judgment and deliberation.
The deliberative skill or the deliberative art.
We only deliberate.
Aristotle says over things where there is some choice,
uh,
we deliberate with an eye to preservation or change to making something better
or to preserve it from becoming worse.
This kind of knowledge will be the arch or craft of the statesman concerned
above all with what to do in a specific situation.
It is the skill possessed by the greatest statesman,
you might say,
the fathers of the constitutions as it were,
who create the permanent framework in which allows later in Leicester figures to
handle a change.
This is the kind of political skill and wisdom,
again,
possessed of the founders of cities.
The,
the legislative founders of,
of,
of regimes in Aristotle's politics is a book about the kind of knowledge
requisite for those con,
that kind of skill.
This quality of practical judgment for nieces.
Practical Wisdom,
uh,
was developed,
I think in a beautiful essay,
uh,
without any explicit reference to Aristotle by the English political
philosopher,
Isaiah Berlin.
Anyone here ever heard of Isaiah Berlin?
Not One of your famous famous English philosopher died a number of years ago in
the late nineties.
Uh,
okay.
But that's,
this will,
this I hope will be an inspiration to you should read Isaiah Berlin.
In any case,
he wrote a wonderful essay called political judgment.
Uh,
and in it he asks,
what is the intellectual quality that successful statesmen possess that
distinguishes them from all other,
the distinguishes their knowledge from all other forms of rationality and
knowledge.
And he writes as follows on a quote him,
the quality that I am attempting to describe Berlin rights is that special
understanding of public life,
which successful statesmen have,
whether they are wicked or virtuous,
which Bismarck had,
or tail around,
or Franklin Roosevelt,
or for that matter,
men such as Cavour or Disraeli,
Gladstone or Ataturk in common with the great psychological novelists and
something which is conspicuously lacking in men have more purely theoretical
genius such as Newton or Einstein or Bertrand Russell or even Freud.
So there too,
like Aristotle,
he distinguishes a kind of practical skill possessed by the greatest minds,
political minds at least,
and says it's quite different in and from what he calls the great psychological
novelist from that possessed of the greatest philosophers and scientists.
What are we to call this capacity?
Uh,
Berlin continues and he writes again as follows,
practical reason perhaps you said as a sense of what will work and what will
not.
It is a capacity for synthesis rather than analysis for knowledge in the sense
in which trainers know their animals or parents,
their children or conductors,
they're orchestras as opposed to that in which chemists know the contents of
their test tubes or mathematicians know the rules,
they're symbols obey those who lack.
He says this quality of practical wisdom,
whatever other qualities they may possess,
no matter how clever it imaginative,
kind,
noble,
attractive,
gifted in other ways they may be,
are correctly regarded as politically inept.
So they're Berlin tells us something about the character of this political
knowledge that Aristotle described is furnished us.
But again,
how is this knowledge acquired or are we just born with it?
Do some people just have it or is it a product of experience?
Aristotle doesn't say,
uh,
but I think the answer is clearly some of both.
It is a quality as I agree with Berlin possessed by some of the great
psychological novelists.
I mentioned the names of Tolstoy and read James and perhaps the greatest of all
Jane Austin,
if you want to know or novelist who employs this great,
uh,
skill of judgement,
discrimination and practical reason,
but it is also a virtue of great statesman.
Principally Berlin mentions Bismarck,
Disraeli Franklin Roosevelt.
I would also add the names of Paraclese.
Lincoln and Churchill read their works,
study their histories.
They provide a virtual education in state craft and how to negotiate a fares in
precisely the way Aristotle would have us do.
And that leads me to the larger question you might say,
which is post throughout the work is all Aristotle's work as a whole.
What is Aristotle's political science?
What is it for?
What is he attempting to do
already you could say to ask this question is to stake a claim.
Does Aristotle have a political science?
Is Science of politics?
And again,
if so,
what is it about
to begin to answer this question?
You might say even begin to think about it in the right way requires that we
stand back from Aristotle's texts for a while and ask some fundamental questions
about it.
What does Aristotle mean by the political?
What is the goal or purpose of the study of politics and what is distinctive
about Aristotle's approach to the study of political things?
Okay.
Today the term political science stands for one among,
uh,
among a number of different disciplines that we call collectively to social
sciences.
This not only includes political science,
but you can now mix sociology,
anthropology,
psychology among others.
Each of these disciplines seeks to give us a handle on a distinctive set of
human actions and interactions.
Economics deals with the transactions involving the production and distribution
of wealth,
sociology with transaction governing status and class anthropology with the
domain of culture and so on.
What is it that political science studies and what is it relation to the other
disciplines.
Okay.
The car of political science,
at least according to Aristotle,
into this degree,
I,
I'm very much an Aristotelian.
What distinguishes from our other studies is the concept of the regime of the
polity or the regime for him is not one branch of human activity.
Among others,
it is the fundamental principle or ordering principle that makes all the others
even possible.
This is why Aristotle does not regard the study of politics is one social
science.
Among others,
it is rather what he calls the master science that determines the rank and place
of all the others within the polity is study of the regime.
That is to see the underlying constitutional principles that govern each order
is what distinguishes Aristotle's from from the other social sciences.
So when you came into this class in the beginning of the semester,
you may have thought you were just signing up for a class in political science
who did not know perhaps that you were coming in to study what he calls the
Masters Science,
the science of Sciences.
In some respects,
it is that priority that Aristotle attributes to the regime did I think is what
distinguishes his kind of political science from that of today.
Today,
you might say political scientists and social scientists,
they're more modest in describing priority to any particular branch of knowledge
with I should say the possible exception of the economists who often will
believe that economic motives and transactions provide the,
provide the key to all possible human behaviors.
Who knows,
maybe they're right,
but Aristotle would deny it.
For Aristotle.
However,
politics has a priority to all the others because as he has argued,
man is the political animal.
To be a political animal means first possess speech or reason that allows us to
participate in a community or a way of life governed by shared standards of
justice and injustice.
Aristotle's political science presupposes and are there were just certain
conception of human beings is linguistic animals who are capable not only of
living together,
so do a range of other species,
but rather sharing in the arrangements of rule.
It is our logos are reason that makes a community possible and also expresses or
create,
you could say a certain latitude or indeterminacy in how our behavior,
uh,
distinguishes us from other species.
It is precisely.
He believes this latitude that makes political communities not only sites of
agreement over shared standards,
but also was,
he says,
sites of moral contestation over justice and injustice.
Politics is about conflict and conflict's over justice.
To be a political animal for him is to engage or to be engaged in this ongoing
conversation and debate over the very nature of justice.
To refuse to participate in that conversation.
To declare oneself an outsider to it,
he says is either to be below humanity or above it.
To be human is to be part of that conversation.
Okay,
so does [inaudible] Aristotle ascribes to politics forces us to consider another
question.
Namely,
what is the purpose of this study?
Why do we engage in it?
At first glance,
this seems to be overwhelmingly obvious to,
to gain knowledge,
to gain more knowledge,
but knowledge of what and for what.
Most people today are attracted to the study of politics because they are
interested in things they've read about in newspapers or seen on TV,
things like elections,
political leaders in parties,
different causes to which they may feel some attraction,
uh,
interested in wars.
And revolutions that they see or have heard about.
And it is to learn more about these things that we come to.
This study of politics.
This is true.
It's true now is it was in the time of Aristotle and Aristotle certainly
recognize that the accumulation of political knowledge,
you might say the gathering of data,
the Organization of facts is very important.
Books three,
four,
five of the politics shows the empirical side of Aristotle's politics.
But again,
let me just pose the question,
what is this knowledge for?
What does Aristotle intend to do with it or want us to do with it?
Politics,
political science,
he tells us in the ethics,
again,
it's not a theoretical subject in the matter of physics or metaphysics or
mathematics.
There is to say it's purpose is not knowledge for its own sake.
Uh,
however important to study of politics may be.
It exists not for the sake of knowledge,
but for action as he tells us for Praxis is his word for action.
Political science exists for the sake of the human good.
And the opening sentence of the politics confirms this.
He says,
we see,
uh,
everyone does everything for the sake of some apparent good.
All action or human behavior is aimed at achieving some type of good is are
aimed,
aimed at action
or political action aims at preservation or change.
When we act,
we seek to preserve or to change our political action,
you might say is guided by the idea of better or worse.
It implies a standard or better and worse.
And this implies some idea of the good by which we judge.
So it follows,
at least Aristotle believes so that the study of politics is not again for the
sake of knowledge for its own sake,
but knowledge that serves the regime there helps to make it better or prevent it
from becoming worse.
It's goal is not just to know more,
but to know how,
and this requires not only theoretic acumen but political judgment and a kind of
practical knowledge that Aristotle discusses at length.
This quality of practical judgment and reflection is against somehow unique to
the political arch or the political skill.
Aristotle tells us it is the ability not only to keep the ship of state afloat,
but allows the greatest statesmen to guide the ship,
to steer it safely to port.
That is to say the kind of knowledge needed by the statesmen
and Aristotle's political science then is ultimately the supreme science of
state craft.
A term that again,
we don't hear much about craft or statesman ship.
It's regarded perhaps by today's political science is to value Laden to uh,
to uh,
subjective to speak of statesmanship or statecraft.
And this too,
again,
it's a word that carries distinctive and strong connotations.
Who was a statesman and what are the attributes of the Statesman?
I've spoken a little about the attributes that Aristotle believes are central to
the state,
to the McGall ups you coast,
the greatest of the Statesman.
This will be quite different.
For example,
from the qualities we will see beginning on Friday and next week that
Machiavelli and later Hobbes or Locke believe are necessary for the great
founders or statesman.
Plato and Aristotle give their own visions.
The philosopher,
king,
uh,
the great soul man or medical ops two coasts.
But the statesmen again is the founder to the highest degree is the founder of
regimes,
laws and institutions.
They provide the constitutional framework within which we later figures,
uh,
operate.
So of Aristotle's state.
Political science is an education for statesmanship.
You might say,
what are its methods?
What are its distinctive methods?
How do we educate a statesman?
How do we educate potential statesman?
This is a question,
what does it,
what are its methods?
This is a question asked,
you might say,
of every mature science.
It is a,
it is possession of a method that distinguishes a mature science from simply a
jumble of facts,
hearsay,
inspired guesses,
or a random collection of insights and observations without a distinctive method
for obtaining and organizing knowledge.
We are are just groping in the dark.
So what is the distinctive method of Aristotle's politics?
To some degree,
Aristotle refuses to play the methodologists game
in a well known passage from the ethics.
He says that our discussions will be adequate if it achieves clarity within the
limits of its subject.
If it achieves clarity within the limits of its subject.
In other words,
he seems to be saying it is wrong to demand methodological purity in a subject
like politics where there is always great variety and unpredictability.
It is the marquee says,
have an educated person,
presumably a liberally educated person not to demand more precision in the
subject matter allows,
but that formulation seems in many ways to be questioned begging because how
much precision does the subject allow?
How do we know?
There will always,
he suggests appear to be something ad hoc about the methods used in the study of
politics.
We will have to let the method fit the subject rather than demanding the subject
matter fit a kind of Apriori method to insist on that kind of methodological
purity he implies would be do impose a false sense of unity,
a false sense of certainty or absoluteness on the study of politics,
which is variable and contingent and always subject to flux and change.
But even while Aristotle may deny that there is a single method appropriate to
the study of politics,
he proposes a set of common questions that political scientists have to address
and he lays out these questions at the very beginning of the fourth book of the
politics.
He lists for such questions.
The political scientist,
he says,
must have a grasp of the best regime given the most favorable circumstances.
Second,
he tells us the political scientists must consider what kind of regime will be
best under less than optimal circumstances.
Third,
the political scientist may have,
some must have some knowledge of how to render any regime,
no matter how imperfect it may be,
more stable and coherent.
And finally,
the political scientist must know something about the techniques of reform and
persuasion,
what we might call the area of political rhetoric by which existing regimes can
be brought closer to the best
and taken together.
These four questions are intended to guide inquiry to shape or direct inquiry.
They are not intended to yield sure or certain results,
but to guide and inform statesmen and citizens in the business of decision
making.
So bearing in mind that political science is a practical science,
a science of judgment,
a science aimed at directing action under specific cir,
cir circumstances and situations.
It is important.
Aristotle finally suggest the language of political science express the common
sense or ordinary language of political actors.
There was virtually no jargon in Aristotle's politics.
Aristotle's political science stays entirely within the orbit of ordinary
speech.
Okay.
Central language does not claim to be scientifically purged of ambiguity,
but rather adopt standards of proof appropriate to people and debates and
assemblies and courts of law and counsel rooms and the like.
The language of Aristotelian political science is the language of man the
political animal.
You will never hear him speaking in terms of dependent or independent variables.
You will never hear him using technical jargon out officially imported into the
science of politics or this study of politics from the outside.
But what most distinguishes Aristotle is that his language is addressed
emphatically to citizens and statesmen,
not too political side,
other political scientists or philosophers.
It has a public orientation.
It is publicly directed.
It is public spirited.
It is concerned with the common good.
Contrast that with today's political science
today it seems political scientists are more concerned with advancing the
abstract truths of science and claims about creating a methodologically rigorous
and pure science of politics where Aristotle is more concerned with the regime,
modern political science in many ways,
stain claims to stand above or apart from the regime to be objective,
to be disinterested as if it were viewing human affairs from a distant planet.
Aristotle takes his stand from within politics and the regime of which he is a
part.
Of course,
we all know contemporary political scientists are not neutral.
They frequently insert their views,
values,
we call them value judgments.
We call them.
They insert them into their discussions.
Yeah,
but these were values are regarded by them,
is purely subjective.
Their own,
again,
their own value judgments,
so to speak,
and not strictly speaking a part of the science of politics,
but we all know doing not that most contemporary political scientists tend to be
liberals.
They're values are liberal values.
This raises a question where did the relation between contemporary political
science and liberalism is merely accidental or there,
whether there is some intrinsic,
some necessary connection between them.
So when might do well to ponder,
yeah.
Which political science is really more scientific,
Aristotle's,
which is explicitly and necessarily evaluative,
and that offers advice and exhortation to the statesmen and citizens about what?
About how to care for their regime or contemporary political science that claims
to be neutral and nonpartisan,
but which smuggles its values and preferences in always through the back door.
And,
and this very partisan note,
I conclude.
So,
uh,
on Friday,
let me just remind you,
you'll crunchy pay with studying Machiavelli.